so
stop bigcon.com now exists
to begin with
um
it's been a while
either this
has to stop
or
I'm going to have to stop
either this what I'm about to discuss
has to stop
or I don't know this uh
this may just not be for me anymore so
let me explain give me a few minutes of
your time because context matters here I
ask that you don't skip ahead it won't
take very long
this has been a long time coming this is
a conversation that I've actively
avoided
sidestepped and I've hoped and prayed
that it not be necessary behind the
scenes for a long while
but that's no longer possible so
if you've watched for the last decade
you know that I've always made it clear
that we here at mug Club are in the
business of serving you
the viewer you watching listening right
now I've also made it clear that I
wouldn't be in the business of attacking
other conservatives regardless
of disagreements or personal issues and
I've always explained my logic was
relatively simple I believe that the
world was better with more voices out
there rather than less regardless of
minute differences considering the
magnitude of the battle that we are
genuinely fighting for our country right
now
but for the first time I have to say
that I believe many of those in charge
in the right-leaning media
are actually at odds with what's best
for you
the viewer
the customer and more importantly the
country
we here at my club we thought that we
were all in this together that we were
fighting the the media entertainment
industrial complex
we thought that we were all genuinely
taking it to Big Tech
but too many of those in charge
of
the big conservative platforms are
verifiably in bed with them
big Tech is in bed with big con
the people you thought
the people I thought were fighting for
you
a lot of it has been
a big con now I'm specifically avoiding
naming names or going after individuals
in this video
because I genuinely hope that those I'm
addressing and you know who you are have
a change of heart
it's it's never too late to do the right
thing
guys
this is a genuine plea we can all do
better
we can all do better it doesn't have to
be this way and please
don't make me have to provide receipts
now to the others out there
who have now been able to verify
have been locked into exploitative
contracts that I have the luxury of not
having to sign which is why I'm doing
this
um those of you out there who've been
locked into this and and you know
what I'm talking about stay tuned I've
got something for you before this video
is done
so
a few points to address now many many
but not all of the suits running the
business of of big conservative big con
at best don't share your values and at
worst are taking advantage of your good
graces
and as I've experienced it behind the
scenes I've watched our country be
harmed as a result
so mug Club
professionally it's meant everything to
us here
um personally too but professionally you
are the entire reason for our ability
your ability to create this kind of
content truly independently for the last
six years when I started doing you know
right leaning like comedy entertainment
videos uh in 2009 maybe it was 2008 I
really didn't have a plan I didn't know
the blueprint because there was no
blueprint I didn't know the ceiling
because no one with this kind of content
had ever really even tried it it was you
mug Club
you watching supporting who created the
ceiling and you made it clear that all
of you were going to keep raising it all
I knew back then was that I was a
conservative I was a Christian there was
nothing out there
for someone like me not on cable not on
radio certainly not on YouTube
and back then that was really the only
video platform uh live streaming wasn't
really even a thing
all I wanted to do was to set out to
create the kind of content
the kind of show that I always wished
had existed when I was growing up and I
hope that there would be enough
of you out there
like me here's the thing I was told
that there weren't
I was told by the powers that be that
you didn't exist
I was told that the only way to make a
living in this business was to cater to
older conservative generations and that
comedy that entertainment that edgy
quote unquote content didn't work on the
right side of the spectrum
an entertainment show would never work
you all of you are the only reason
that I that we hear were even remotely
Vindicated
and Mud Club sealed it
I remember exactly where I was when I
thought up the idea of mug Club I
remember who I was with
I remember what I was eating I remember
why
I could see the writing on the wall back
then the big Tech censorship on the
horizon the diminishing advertising
Revenue day by day and I knew full well
that demonetization from these platforms
it was inevitable uh but I wasn't really
sure that this would work at that point
in time getting anyone to subscribe to
anything was pretty much impossible
everything on the internet was basically
free except for pornography even you
know Netflix the only player in the
space at the time between shipping DVDs
of poltergeist three uh they were
struggling with online streaming
but I found a great partnership back
then a partnership with a company called
crtv which later purchased the Blaze and
used that name going forward
and on Election night 2016 so many of
you signed up at the back end of our
site crashed we couldn't handle it and
it only Grew From there now I want to be
clear about something
uh this video here it's not about the
blaze uh when they were purchased by
crtv the company's goals their vision
simply grew further apart from from mine
um from ours here just it just wasn't
the right fit
yeah you know I wasn't thrilled about
some things and the you know handling of
mug Club leaving and that's why but you
know we launched mugclub forever.com
where you can sign up just to be able to
reach you
this really isn't about that so I want
to create some separation here business
relationships end all the time that's
business but I was
in a period to field offers
from other people other key players in
this movement they flooded in now before
you guess who it is
before you start trying to do some some
Sherlock Holmes work um there are far
more people beneath the tip of the
iceberg than you know about who are
trying to get into the space
there are more than you would probably
assume so I went into free agency I
looked
over the offers
and I saw the Clause come out
and I don't just mean unreasonable
demands for control but what what I
would argue
are immoral terms that actually punish
conservative content creators on behalf
of big Tech
and that's something that I just
couldn't unsee and I want to it's not
the exception it's the rule kids kids
out there coming up we need to build a
bench here in this movement
it's almost impossible don't sign don't
sign these contracts
I know I now know what you are signing
out there I have the luxury of not
having to
I don't have to be here I don't have to
say this please
don't sign this certainly not without
professional legal counsel
representation do not sign something
that includes you know let me go through
this
effectively uh
ownership of all your social media
platforms channels and perpetuity the
rights to your content name image
likeness
um
even the ones that you've built
don't sign contracts out there that
include
multi-million dollar penalties
for different let me read you an example
of what I mean
um
and this would be if it was me
if Crowder fails to deliver a monthly
content uh in any month or any of the
quarterly content in the corner
including any and all ad reads and by
the way all these contracts came with
three four five
ad reads per show which would
fundamentally change what this show is
got to get those dollar dollar bills
if I failed to do that it would be a 250
000 reduction
in fee per quarter
if let's say uh
we did do everything per quarter but
annually maybe missed something like
let's say we went and did it change my
mind instead of a Daily Show which of
course requires a lot more work it'd be
a separate one million dollar penalty
for that if you miss a single piece of
content
and the amount of content required is
not in line with frankly it's worse than
Disney it's worse than ABC it's worse
than NBC it's worse than CBS
this is ownership of you and everything
that you do but here's just to drive it
home
don't sign something that has another
100
000 dollar
daily penalty
if it's not signed off huh beforehand
you get a you get hit by a car you have
a sick day
you could lose a hundred thousand
dollars a day
hey anyone wonder why there's burnout in
this anyone wonder why you have kids
come up and they leave
they never come back you think if you
had that kind of a penalty think if
someone said hey we're going to penalize
you ten thousand dollars
every day you miss coming into work you
think you'd be stressed
this is worse than the left frames their
contracts again I don't of course I
didn't sign any of these things
but I now know what other kids are
signing out there and here's the worst
part yeah that's terrible I think it's
um
I just think that's wrong to treat
people that way
but this is where in going through this
and I need to take some time because
look I've always tried to be a happy
warrior uh and I want to go back to that
I haven't I haven't been happy for a
while
to be really I haven't been happy for a
while because when you know what goes on
behind these scenes
and you see how many people are
complicit
it creates an air of hopelessness
it really does
where you think the people are supposed
to be linking arms and fighting with you
fighting for you want to punish you so
here's the worst part do not kids under
any circumstances sign a contract with
people who claim to be conservative
but will penalize you
25 percent
for any demonetization or sponsor
boycott look let me read this to you
if any of the major platforms
oh no sorry that's the second one let me
go back to the first one there's another
20 it's 45 to get a Content strike let's
start with a demonetization
if blank is boycotted or dropped by more
than 50 percent
of uh the advertising partners
the company is not able to replace them
within 90 days the fee will be reduced
by 25 percent
uh that's a sponsorship boycott so
that's saying hey
liberals boycotts work
they work on our guys
will punish them for you let me go on
specifically YouTube demonetization
if any of the major platforms issues a
Content strike such that Crowder cannot
be monetized on such platform
and the company is not able to resolve
the issue within 90 days the fee will be
reduced by 25
moving forward now I thought this was a
mistake because you know these people
maybe didn't know who I am that we've
been demonetized for three years
no it was made very clear to me in no
uncertain terms this is what's sent out
to everybody
and then if you get then if you get a
strike
meaning a suspension another 20 percent
reduction
and then another 20 of it happens on
Apple and then another 10 of happens on
Facebook and then another 10 of it
happens on Spotify
imagine you're de-platformed
as we've seen in the past where all the
major entities decide to remove you in
one day rather than having a
conservative alternative you would now
be down to five to fifteen percent of
the revenue of your contract
foreign
think about think about this for a
second those in charge
a big conservative the big con and it
really is the biggest con going right
now they're making it known in their
contracts
that they will enforce the guidelines of
big Tech and punish conservatives on
their behalf don't hey don't don't worry
wojinski these could trust me these
conservatives will stay in line if they
get demonetized we take away 25 percent
of their operating budget take another
20 away if they get a hard strike hey
don't worry Zuckerberg we've got your
back hope to see you at the UFC Apex
let me let me ask you can you imagine if
this show
Not only was never permitted to take
risks per our contract as it relates to
uh big Tech guidelines like as far as
the content guidelines right there's
content guidelines and there's
Advertiser guidelines can you imagine
just imagine a world where this show
could never take risks in relation to
those guidelines I'd say things like
mRNA injections election Integrity take
your pick but one step further if this
show had to be Advertiser friendly on
YouTube
those guidelines pretty much read don't
say anything offensive ever well what's
offensive whatever is stuck in Susan
wojinski's craw that day
I wish those at the top
in big conservative
with granted yeah a lot of the money
wanted to do better
but they don't
that's why
I've created stop bigcon.com and you can
be a signatory and our plans therein
look like I said I have the luxury of
not signing this I don't need it I've
been demonetized for years uh We've
adapted here precisely because of mug
Club
you know the free content only exists
because of those who subscribe I promise
you we won't do more than one
sponsorship spot per show I will keep my
word on that until this show ends
why because it's designed for you it's
not designed for the sponsors
if it's four five six seven sponsors
they're no longer the product you're the
product
so we've adapted here
I don't need this we've been demonetized
and we're not beholden
to sponsors who might get boycotted
because the sponsors that we have are
going to go wherever we go anyway we
know that Beyond any shadow of a doubt
that's the luxury of doing business
honestly
and loyalty but to the kids out there
coming up who don't have that luxury
please don't sign these
you can do better we can all do better
and the only reason at this point
for me to stay and continue doing what
I've been doing
is to make sure that we all do
that we all do better so to everyone out
there who refuses to sign or is under
the cloud
of these maybe not entirely enforceable
contracts look
here
's your signal water's warm here
I'll produce your show we'll produce
your show
if there are enough of you out there I
will transition mug Club
into a full-scale network with
independent content creators who don't
want to be locked into slave contracts
look I understand that business
relationships sometimes fall through
people don't see eye to I I get that but
there is a way to structure these
contracts and a network there's a world
in which contracts and a network exists
where everyone benefits with some
semblance of fairness transparency
there's no need to be enslaved like this
if you're out there right now and you're
making content work on whatever scale
that may be there are levels to this
game I understand that
and you'd like to have some backup
you'd like to have some brothers sisters
Z's and arms some security without
losing your shirt
send your email to creators ladder with
crowder.com and we'll talk you want a
partnership great
can probably work something out
you want the security of being an
employee you could probably make that
work too
there are many ways to skin this cat and
you know what
if mug club or whatever Network it
becomes isn't for you if this isn't the
right home for you
we have lawyers in representation who
will negotiate your contract for you
with anyone else out there
at half the market rate
why because I don't like this and I'm
going to end this we all need to end
this together I have plenty of friends I
could use a few enemies there is
strength in numbers and if you watching
right now right now if you want a
network that you can truly call your own
I just ask that you enter in your email
at stopbegcon.com
entering in your email makes you a
signatory it's a statement
that you want
not just mugler but you want a network
that does better
so
it's either time for
mug club to go big or it's time for me
to go home
I can't change this all by myself
I really can
and frankly swimming Upstream with just
this one show it's
it's a feudal endeavor
so either Mud Club grows and we you
start setting the standard for this
Movement we write this ship or you know
what I'll go back
to doing maybe occasional videos stand
up I don't
I don't need to do this it's that simple
my life would be less complicated
how I just want you to think about this
for a second there's a reason that
if you felt this way let me put it this
way and I've heard feedback from you
if you feel in your gut that a lot of
conservative content out there feels
homogeneous feels sanitized
feels like they're they're missing some
key points there's a reason for that
there's a reason that you know you you
often find yourself asking hey I wonder
why X won't talk about why
and I don't know any contract that I
would have signed would have turned this
into yet another softer radio show on
video littered with live reads for every
sponsor that could be crammed into every
single episode possible devoid of the
sketches to change my mind type segments
the spontaneity the levity that's made
this show exactly what it is oh and by
the way I was told would never work by
the same powers that be
and the real reason the stakes are so
high
for us here but me specifically look
either I'm a break glass in case of
emergency candidate here
just to start a network
and to actually start helping people out
there who
who don't have don't enjoy the same
luxuries that we do of being independent
either that's my role moving forward or
this isn't for me
and here's the thing all at once it kind
of hit me and I had to take some time I
hope you understand to
to really pray and and contemplate this
and it hit me after all of these years
even after all this time after all of
you have voted with your dollar
and your viewership and your support
you've shown what's possible
in supporting this the largest the
largest show in the conservative
movement Bar None Bar None just to be
clear and I don't often advertise that I
don't lead my show with that I want the
content to speak for itself
but I also realize that you need to
understand you're a part of something
bigger than maybe you realize it's the
biggest show in the movement bar none
the last election night on Rumble
bigger numbers than any mainstream show
on YouTube that's significant that's you
well I'm grateful and humble false
humility doesn't
it does you a disservice
but even after all this time after all
of you have voted with your dollar with
your viewership with your support after
you've set records
it wasn't and it's not I should say in
the present tense it's not that the
suit's in charge of these places big con
and these sites these media companies
it's not that they still believe that
this show
can't work
it's not that they any longer believe
that you don't exist
those at the top
those pulling the strings in VidCon are
bothered precisely by the fact that you
do
they don't want a group of rebellious
rabble rousers
who want to learn fight like hell and
laugh together
you have no value if you can't all be
kept in line to some degree
I don't mean some master plan to
eliminate you just subdue you a little
bit just soften your edges a little bit
just play ball a little more
so we can keep our content all monetized
and keep having cocktails with those in
charge of big Tech
they want you
to do that and they're forcing many of
the people you watch to do that
I can't do that
I can't do that and I'm willing to bet
that most of you watching right now
can't do that but okay you know what no
let me let me rephrase
of course I could of course I could do
that
I won't
I won't do that
and I'm willing to bet that most of you
won't either
let me know just how many of you won't
enter in your email at stopbegcon.com
now I just need some time to figure out
how to do this the requirement for
infrastructure
is Light Years beyond what we would need
for just this show some time to solve
this puzzle has to how I can best and
most efficiently accommodate you and
hopefully sometimes restore my faith in
a movement which frankly has been um
shaken by some not all there are a lot
of good people in this movement but some
really bad actors Among Us and rather
than throw anyone under the bus or
continue this long drawn out drama
playing out in the Public Square I'd
rather focus on how to serve you the
only people who truly matter in this
movement and to this company and I would
say to the future of this country you
the average American who's watched not
the person who's creating the content
and from the contracts you right now at
home in your car in your truck Wherever
You Are
Hands on the Wheel
so in the interim as I figure this out
uh pardon my dust I'll still be on my
social media Pages the silence is is
over now I know I've been sort of uh
sort of gone to to radio silence um I'll
still be doing stand-up shows that you
can always check out at uh lottery.com
tour I'll actually probably do some more
of those I think I'm in Kentucky uh
February 10th you can go and check it
out
um I might even upload the occasional
video
I don't know also
you know I don't really do a lot of
press the last time I did it was I think
the Vox apocalypse because I just do
this show
yeah for the first time in a while I'll
make myself available I'll talk about
this
so anyone who want anyone who wants to
learn more anyone who has the balls
to talk about this as it isn't afraid
from the backlash of maybe not getting
the guests from the people who want to
try and pinch us uh you can send an
email to Media louderwithcrowder.com I'm
sending your increase here I'll make
myself available
to talk about this now if
if we are going to keep doing this we
need to do it right and I need to do
this in a way that does right by you
because you are the future of this
country you are the Catalyst for change
not some major Media Company not some
guy in a boardroom figuring out ways to
sell you more reverse mortgages gold or
[ __ ] pocket catheters it's you it's
always been you
those in big con would do well to not
lose sight of that so I want to be clear
make no mistake the Liberals out there
filming at the mouth this is not me
turning against conservatism or an
incident of friendly fire at all
everything that I've ever stood for I'm
standing for now
it's precisely because I believe what I
say that I'm doing this
and by the way too many of these people
aren't our friends so this is the last
call
to those conservative businesses and on
the big con
you have a chance join me in making this
right
you know you've lost your way it's never
too late to correct the course we can
all work together and fix this it
doesn't have it doesn't have to be this
way it doesn't have to be this way
there's no reason that it is this way
I don't I don't know why I've tried to
get an answer I don't understand it it
doesn't have to be this way let's all
reset and do it right
and if not
hey I'll do it without you
and mug Club is coming for all of it
the viewers
and the talent
now to everyone else everyone who's
watched listened paid attention in any
way
um
either right now or throughout the years
I just ask that you join me in letting
them know that there are far more of us
far more of you than of them demand
change demand better be a signatory
that's what this is it's not just
entering in your email it's
it's letting these people know
at big con
that you want something different that
you require better because you know what
I am going to March into these people's
offices these nameless faceless people's
offices with your declaration
and the number of you who exist those in
big con are personally going to know
just how many of you are equally pissed
you and the number of you out there
are officially going to be their report
card not a handful of old money
billionaires not career political and
non-profit lobbyists you
you are signatory this is their report
card
and all of you
are the Reckoning
and if enough of you draft me
fine I'll be your instrument
otherwise what are we doing here
stop bigcon.com
please enter in your email comment below
hit the like all of that because it
helps the algorithm and you make sure
that they see this
and stay tuned
it's probably going to be a little bit
of a bumpy ride